[Musik]
bild grieg news
für uns vor ort vielleicht können wir
ihnen dazu holen wir haben die
information bekommen dass bundeskanzler
olaf scholz in manuel makro und auch
mario draghi soeben das hotel verlassen
und sich auf den weg machen wohin das
wissen wir noch nicht hier sehen wir
paul ronzheimer paul kannst du uns schon
hören
ja wie ich kann euch hören es gibt in
diesem moment sirenenalarm und hier wir
haben gerade sie sehen gehört in diesem
moment ausgerechnet als der
bundeskanzler sich auf den weg machen
will also zweimal sirenenalarm in kiew
aber noch sehen wir wir hören und diesem
moment sirenenalarm in kiew während der
bundeskanzler hier in der stadt es in
dem moment wo er sich auch machen will
vom hotel in ein sehr wahrscheinlich der
vororte der stadt und wir sehen hier
auch die flaggen vor diesem hotel jetzt
ist die frage ist sind die delegation
bleibt in diesem moment noch vollkommen
ruhig wir zeigen die einmal dort in
diesem moment
wir sind dort ist die delegation dort
warten wir auf den bundeskanzler und
dort sind auch die sicherheitsbeamten
[Musik]
das sind die sirenen die wir immer
wieder hier im tier gehört haben wir vor
allem im februar im märz dann
ausgerechnet im moment als der
bundeskanzler hier ist
sirenenalarm ausgerechnet jetzt was
bedeutet das für die weitere
tagesplanung ich hier geh mal davon aus
dass die ganze sicherheits delegationen
dieser 13 minister aufregung ist
das ist noch ein bisschen unklar was
jetzt genau passiert aber wir erleben
das natürlich in einem moment wo der
bundeskanzler jetzt richtung eventuell
einer dieser vororte wo es eine sirene
an haben gibt in der hauptstadt ist
unklar ist wir sind dort sehr viele
sicherheitsbeamte lot of security
unterberg your ass das sind unter
anderem deutsche aber auch französische
sicherheitskräfte
nun müssten die 30 nicht jetzt
eigentlich in sicherheit gegeben gibt es
dort wo welche schutzräume bunker in der
nähe
die gibt es hier in der nähe wir sehen
dort aber die delegation unter anderem
der regierungssprecher der
außenpolitische berater die dort in der
mitte stehen jens plötner steffen
hebestreit die noch sehr entspannt dort
sind sie warten in diesem moment auf den
bundeskanzler haben sonnenbrillen auf
wirken sehr entspannt wir sehen noch
niemanden der jetzt hier irgendwie in
richtung bunker oder in richtung keller
laufen würde das ist man in kiew auch
nicht mehr gewöhnt also wenn es hier
eine sirene gibt normalerweise passiert
das nicht aber noch einmal der
bundeskanzler hat das hotel noch nicht
wieder verlassen also er ist im gebäude
das bedeutet er könnte wenn er wollte
sich dort in sicherheit bringen
wir sehen allerdings du sagst es auch
bislang die delegationen noch
einigermaßen ruhig und sie gehen auch in
ihre autos und fahren tatsächlich jetzt
los jetzt haben wir gesehen das war zum
beispiel die italienische delegation
poul kontinent erklärt mario draghi
eingestiegen ist
[Musik]
nein ich habe mario draghi dort nicht
gesehen aber das sind italienische
carabinieri hier hinter mir und dort
sieht man die deutsche delegation hier
auf der linken seite gerade aus da ist
einmal der wirtschaftspolitische berater
der außenpolitische berater ist die
botschafterin die deutsche botschafterin
in der ukraine und der
regierungssprecher die dort auf olaf
scholz waren aber wie gesagt es gab
gerade viermal sirenenalarm in der
hauptstadt ihren während bundeskanzler
olaf scholz die stadt besucht während er
hier in der ukraine ist
die genannten informationen vor ort in
kiew bitte melde dich sofort sobald es
etwas neues gibt